So within in a day after the
earthquake
it starts to fill up the little by little with people
mostly they were just camping out under sheeted
tents
just with some wood and covered by a regular sheet
or wood or whatever they could find
it's just amazing because it's a week ago
all of this was people with sheets over the sticks
and its just
transformed
into like, look at that thats people with a little store selling liquor
and cigarettes
people recognize that
they've been living there for a long time
and so a lot of good things are just re-claimed
from the
damaged buildings around the city
mostly made out or wood and tin
and everything day that I come here there are more
and more and more people
and now I think they are about thirty or thirty-five
thousand people here
I think that as everyone realises how slow tents and shelter
are coming they
they have resigned and  kind of deal with things themselves
the health issues range from
Malaria in Haiti and so thats mosquitos
and so theres daytan fever in the city
especially daytime mosquitos
there certainly be problem of rats and malnutrition just because people
do not have access to proper food
then when you look at people living very
close together their problems are sanitation
and
the bad sensation goes along with diareahal disease
with typhoid
and just with general and
misery to be honest with living with bad sanitation
and it brings fly and more mosquitos
the other issue is more a safety issue is a
fire hazard in a place like this is absolutely huge
people's houses are very very close together
now they're made of wood but many are made of plastic or sheeting
like sheets from their bed
and people cook with open fire with charcoals and soother risk
and they are burning rubbish as well
so in he dry season where everything is tender and ready
its really really concerning to me and other people that there would be a major fire in one of these settlement areas
alnmi lasante
started what we are calling mobile clinics but what they really are
are comprehensive
primary health care posts
okay so the triage areas over there, they're waiting so they get triaged either here or over here so  were kind of scaling up
we saw about 700 people
in the very first day because people don't have health care
for a few weeks
and so we made what we are calling a health passport
so that the next time they are seen by a medical organization
they have their medical record written down now
we have a team of about twenty doctors,
nurses, lab technicians, pharmicists and we do have primary
health care with reproductive health and women's health
and HIV testing, and each day we are adding more services to what we are doing
so we want to avoid just doing first aid, where
0:03:14.389,0:03:16.829
we are bandaging wounds and things like that
and get into comprehensive primary health care
because these people are going to be living here for
a long time
they know that people anyone else had
admitted it because they are putting up their posts and houses
and so they are going to need primary health care
the sound of people hitting their tin, the sound to me just
it just means that this represents the resiliance
of Haitians, because they are like we're here, we're still here
they have accepted the fast that they are not going anywhere
so let me build a small shelter and let me do the best that I can